people who just you know look at by
matches with deep blue 20 years ago or
recent games are played by newer
machines in in God or in popular
videogame daughter they miss a very
important point that we in all these
cases though these games are different
and go for instance much more complex
than chess it's more abstract more
strategic so it's more difficult to
accumulate his sophisticated knowledge
as we did in chess but all these games
they represent closed systems which
means we humans field machine with was a
target with rules there's no automatic
transfer of the knowledge that machines
could accumulate in closed systems to
open-ended systems machines can do many
things and they will learn even more
things in the future but I don't see any
chance in the foreseeable future for
machines to ask the right questions now
they can ask questions but they don't
know what questions are relevant